In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for September 24, on which we commemorate, the holy and
great proto-marter, Thakla, equal to the apostles.
On the 24th of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy proto-marter and equal to the
apostles, Thakla.
And Thakla came from the city of Econium, an Asia minor, and was the daughter of a rich
pagan called Theoclius.
She was betrothed at the age of 18 to a young man called Thamaris, who loved her dearly.
It was the time that St. Paul, coming down from Antioch, stayed in Econium at the house
of Onesiferus, a neighbor of Thakla, and taught the Word of God there night and day.
To all those listening to him, with great joy, he said,
Blessed are the pure in heart, for they shall see God.
Blessed are those who guard the chastity of their flesh, for they shall be the temple of God.
Blessed are those who have renounced this world, for they shall be acceptable to God.
Blessed are those who fear the words of God, for they shall be comforted.
Blessed are those who embrace the wisdom of Jesus Christ, for they shall be called sons of
the most high.
Blessed are those who have guarded their baptism, for they shall find rest with the Father
and the Son.
Blessed are those who have understood the knowledge of Jesus Christ, for they shall be in the light.
Blessed are those who have rejected the outward appearances of this world, for the love of God.
For they shall judge the angels, and shall be glorified at the right hand of the Father.
Blessed are the bodies of the virgins, for the word of the Father shall be their justification
in the day of his Son, and they shall enjoy rest forever and ever.
As she listened to Paul's heavenly words from behind a curtain, where she stayed hidden
for three days, Thecla overcome by joy was drawn as it were irresistibly to the faith.
When they saw her, unmindful of everything earthly, attaching herself to the words of this
stranger, who advocated turning aside from marriage, the occluses and themaris were most
disturbed.
The whole city, too, was in an uproar, which is why Paul was seized and brought before
the governor, who ordered him to be put in chains and taken to prison.
At night, Thecla came in search of him.
She gave her bracelets to the jailer and sat at Paul's feet, kissing his chains as he spoke
to her of the mighty works of God.
When Thecla was discovered in the company of Paul, in the same bond of divine love, both
of them were brought before the governor.
As she gave no answer to his questions, Thecla's own mother cried out, burn this enemy
of marriage in the middle of the amphitheater as a terrifying example to all other women.
In order to satisfy the crowd, the governor reluctantly had Paul, flogged and driven out of the city,
and he condemned Thecla to be burnt alive.
She was led naked to the place of execution, while young men and women in a fever of activity
collected wood for the stake.
Then, under the appearance of Paul, Thecla saw the Savior, who filled her with divine power
as she looked upon him, arming herself with the sign of the cross.
She mounted the stake.
The flames flared up, but the fire did not touch her.
Moved by her love, God sent a heavy fall of rain that quenched the flames and filled the
amphitheater with water.
Paul was hiding with only Sephirus and his household in a tomb outside the city.
Thecla was brought by God to join him there, and together they set out for Antioch.
Just as they entered the city, Alexander, one of the worthies of the place, smitten by
Thecla's beauty, rushed to embrace her in the open street.
She defended herself tearing his mantle and the wreath from his head.
In revenge for being made a laughing stock, Alexander handed her over to the governor who condemned
her to the beasts.
She was tied to a fierce lioness that did nothing but lick her feet in reverence for her virginity.
The next day many beasts were loosed on her, but none was able to touch her, protected
as she was by the lioness.
When she saw a deep ditch filled with water and voracious animals in readiness for a new
torment, Thecla cried out, now is the time to take the bath of the new birth.
And throwing herself into the water she cried, in the name of Jesus Christ, I baptize myself
unto my last day.
A shudder ran through the crowd at the thought of such comeliness being devoured, but in
the very moment that she plunged into the water, a flash of lightning struck the beasts,
which came up dead to the surface, and a fiery cloud veiled the nakedness of the bride of
Christ.
Thecla was then given over to other animals more fearsome still, but the women of the city
deeply offended at the lawless condemnation of their sister, screamed and shouted.
Some threw herbs and others nard, Cassia and Amumum, filling the amphitheater with perfume
so that the beasts became drowsy and did not so much as touch the saint.
Thecla was then tied to the hooves of two bulls that were maddened with red-hot irons, as
they leapt about, the flame spread out in a circle and burnt the ropes, leaving the saint
as if she had never been bound.
Seeing all their devices of no avail against the handmaid of God, the governor and Alexander
set her at liberty.
For some days Thecla rested in the house of Trefina, a rich lady of the city who had taken
her as a daughter since the beginning of her tribulations.
But Thecla thought only of finding Paul again, and so made her way to Mira.
She returned thence with Paul to proclaim the mighty works of God in Econium.
There she found Thamiri's dead, and her mother stubbornly deaf to the tidings of salvation,
and so departed to Salusia.
She led the ascetic life for almost 72 years in a cave on Mount Kalamon, not far from the
city, waging fierce war against the demons and renowned for many miracles she worked.
In envy of her reputation, the pagan doctors of the town sent disillute young men to
outrage her, but God provided for Saint Thecla to enter alive into the rock and to disappear
beneath the earth.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.